what's up has come to dominate the
global instant messaging space yeah why
do they still struggle to catch a breath
in America
[Music]
welcome to Hari savvis what's up a she
goes back a lot longer than you would
think all the way back to 2009 it all
started when Brian Acton and Jan koum
left Yahoo in September of 2007 after
quainter jobs a yahoo there go take some
time off in South America and then
return and apply for jobs at Facebook
but then both be rejected in January of
2009 after buy an iPhone that to realize
the potential of the App Store soon
after the two meet up with whose friend
Alex Fishman in San Jose and discuss a
new type of messaging app the idea was
to show statuses next to individual
names of people obviously the idea
needed work but this is where they
started they needed an iPhone developer
and they would make the Russian
developer eager Solomonic off to a
website called rentacoder calm comb
would then name the app and as you
probably already guessed it was named
after the phrase what's up on February
24th 2009 it would incorporate what's
the pink in California but when early
versus our whatsapp kept crashing whom a
she strongly considered giving up and
getting a real job act encouraged him to
stay just a couple of more months before
completely quitting in June of 2009
upward launched push notifications this
painted user's notifications about the
app even when they weren't using the app
this is very simple nowadays but back
then this was a pretty big thing whom
instantly updated the app to accommodate
for push notifications he allowed users
to get pinged whenever their friend
status would change and soon after he
would release what's up beta 2.0 until
now there was some active users here and
there but after this release the user
account would significantly increase the
250,000 people at this point Acton was
also working on another startup but he
was stopped working there and fully
devoted his time to whatsapp on top of
this he would actually be successful at
persuading five of his former yahoo
friends in investing $250,000 in seed
fund
into what's up after doing this actor
will officially joined the company and
become a co-founder and the same month
they would exclusively launch the app on
the App Store after months in the beta
stages who would hire a friend in LA
crisp effort to develop a blackberry
version which would come out two months
the app was very cheap to run in fact
the only real cost that they had was
selling the verification text messages
at the beginning and this is why they
used to charge $0.99 per year mainly to
cover these costs in December of 2009
they would add the ability to send
photos and from then it really took off
and by early 2011 it would be in the top
20 apps on the App Store and in April of
2011 say KIAC Apple would invest 8
million dollars for a little more than
15% of the company by February of 2013
whatsapp would have 200 million monthly
active users and 50 staff members a
little later
Takia coppola would invest another 50
million dollars into whatsapp with the
valuation of 1.5 billion dollars this
time and on February 19 2014 Facebook
announced they're going to be acquiring
whatsapp for 19 billion dollars to this
state this is Facebook's largest
acquisition they paid for it in four
billion dollars in cold hard cash 12
billion Facebook shares and 3 billion
and restricted stocks for cumin Acton at
the time this was also a large
acquisition of a venture-backed company
Tsuchiya Capital got a 5,000 percent
return on their investment and here's a
quick fact whom actually signed the
paperwork to Facebook acquisition on his
former welfare office were used to get
food stamps from and since then whatsapp
has really exploded in fact over 50
percent of the population in Germany
Brazil and Malaysia have whatsapp and
that was in the end of 2016 by now many
other countries have probably joined the
list but the US has pretty much always
lagged behind in that same statistic
only 16 percent of the US population at
a whatsapp so what went wrong the first
point is that most Americans have
unlimited calls and texts on their
phones already you really can't get a
phone plan in a mirror
from the big companies that doesn't have
unlimited talk and text
and now after t-mobile has really
increased a competition for cheaper data
most people have unlimited data as well
the price of unlimited everything in
America significantly come down even at
Verizon you can get a single line of $75
a couple of years ago even from cheaper
providers you could only get a couple of
gigabytes for that price one of the main
reason that people use whatsapp outside
of the United States is to save on SMS
charges but when you already have
unlimited texting it really defeats the
purpose of getting whatsapp for
Americans it's actually more expensive
to text to data base most Americans have
unlimited talk and text but not everyone
has unlimited data as of yet but that's
probably going to change as well in the
next couple of years
well one of the main reasons to get
whatsapp is not really applicable to
most Americans it makes sense that
Muslims don't really have it one of the
main reasons that whatsapp is so popular
in European countries isn't Europeans
travel a lot internationally especially
a lot more often when compared to
Americans the eurozone and proximity of
countries really makes international
traveling much easier in Europe for
Americans first of all there's simply no
reason to leave America all the
opportunities that you can think of
already exists within America if you
want to act you can go to Hollywood in
California or if you want to do finance
you can go to New York up in the East
the only reason that Americans leave
America is vacation or business purposes
and when you're only on vacation for a
week or two you really don't feel the
need to text anyone back home when
you're on vacation enjoying Paris or
London and then we have frequent
international and business travelers in
America and these people are pretty much
the only people in America who take
advantage of whatsapp the other thing is
that I phones are very popular within
America most people have iPhones and
people are just use iMessage if they're
so inclined to actually text through
data in fact iPhones are so popular in
America that people usually get mad at
the one friend who doesn't have an
iPhone for some reason there's always
that one guy who makes a iMessage group
chat dream and even doing international
travel you can just use iMessage to
contact family so the incentive of data
thing really doesn't apply to most
Americans mainly because Americans don't
really travel internationally and if
they do they can probably just use
iMessage it's very uncommon to find an
American car outside of the country who
doesn't have an iPhone and wants a text
through data one of the other reasons
that whatsapp is so popular in
developing countries like China and
India is to contact friends and family
who moved abroad the iPhone is not all
popular in India so I message really
wasn't a viable choice as a result
what's up was the perfect app for this
use case but the thing is most Americans
don't have friends or family outside of
the country America is a big country
with vast opportunities cuz it really is
never a reason to move away and the
thing is for whatever reason if you ever
need data based texting iMessage is not
Bible there are so many other
alternatives and it's not like Americans
don't use messenger apps it's just that
they don't use it for the same reasons
that people use whatsapp and when
Americans are trying to use a messenger
app they'll most likely turn to Facebook
Messenger or Google hanga which already
have a strong hold on the US market with
classic SMS iMessage and messenger apps
like these Americans have everything
they need to contact anyone they need to
in the world so they really don't need a
third service like whatsapp that doesn't
do anything different or better
and finally Americans love their privacy
a lot if there is any chance of their
personal space being compromised they
don't want to use a product what stop
was literally based on your just being
able to tell if their friends are online
or when they were last online many
Americans see this as an invasion of
privacy and even though you can turn it
off there are other concerns as well you
can do anyone's profile picture and send
anyone any form of media you just need a
phone number you don't need to send a
friend request and you don't even need
to have them in your contacts just a
couple of months ago there was that huge
issue of that Israeli company hacking
into whatsapp apparently they were even
able to breed the digital communications
of iPhone and Android users one of the
main reasons that Americans switch the
messengers is for privacy reasons
and when whatsapp is app most as safe as
just text messaging there's really no
one
for Americans to use it as a resort
Americans stick to good old SMS or
things that they are used to like
facebook Messenger whatsapp is a pretty
simple idea but solves a pretty big
issue worldwide and helps millions of
people the problem is that people in
America aren't affected by the issues
that whatsapp solves in the first place
and for the Americans that whatsapp is
useful there's already so many
alternatives that they were used to and
this is what has really caused whatsapp
to struggle in his home country but
what's up is trying to catch some
momentum with business users and a my
spirit of families and eventually become
popular within the US as well the rest
of the world really seems to love it
so maybe Americans just haven't been
introduced to it yet and if they are
maybe they'll love it as well but that's
all I have for you guys on whatsapp make
your comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this video dimension up a like
and consider subscribing if you like to
see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm Ari I'll see you guys on
the next one